it was a callus calculated attack which
caused terror in manchester
on the 22nd of may 2017 salman abadi
made his way to an ariana grande concert
it was there where he detonated his
homemade bomb murdering 22 people and
injuring hundreds more
five years on the injustice
and the violence of that night and the
pain for many remains
hearing that name amongst the 22 is a
reminder of reality for sharon her
granddaughter olivia would have been 21
this year it's not five years to me it's
like it happened yesterday um
still very raw still very fresh in my
mind
you know i still hear her sort of coming
in the door going granny you know what
she used to do on a friday night when
she came
extremely difficult
today manchester remembered in many ways
from peaceful pondering at the glade of
light memorial
to lining the streets for the city's
great run taking part was freyja on the
night not only was she peppered by
shrapnel she lost her best friend
your body just never expects to go
through that amount of trauma and
especially 29 separate injuries i really
covered head to toe but i think today
especially i'll be holding her close to
my heart because although it's obviously
a day to celebrate how far i've come and
stuff like that and it's still a sad day
thinking about it's been five years
without my best friend
what happened inside the arena changed
not only this city but the country too
from laws around event security
to improving response plans from
emergency services
but still grief anger and a sense of
betrayal haunts many families
five years on
this is a city that never stops but
since its foundations were heavily
shaken five years ago they paused to
remember each year
it was its unity defiance and resilience
that kept it standing then
and continues to now intimate rasheed
sky news manchester